have a seat man how's everything going
I'm exhausted
are you that's everything
congratulations on your show got picked
up for a second season yeah yeah do you
know why you're exhausted you were like
I thought this is going to be a one to
season deal now I gotta go oh no that's
that's the last thing on my mind right
now doing the second season of the show
just because everything is no it's just
been a heavy press week
yes film yeah you don't panic though
when you do a show like do you go
through the thing like I think I'm not
gonna pick it up or he just kinda are
you comfortable just letting it fall
over [ __ ] I think you just enjoy
yourself specially a good comedy you
just make it as good as you can
hopefully but I haven't goodbye I always
assumed they would pick up a
trial-and-error because it's just so
good yeah really a terrific smart comedy
yeah it did take them a while to finally
commit to it because it's it was it was
a challenge you know any time breaking
through to people's consciousness was
something that's that different yeah you
never know whether it's going to
completely work but NBC just loved it
and timing is important I think one of
the reasons that it worked is because
like all the court stuff that goes on
like people are used to it like people
got so wrapped up in making a murderer
and then I got so wrapped up in the FX
OJ series line out here and they got you
know all this stuff is like top of mind
so the idea is that you could follow
this along in a comedy you know you know
what I mean your minds are conditioned
now yeah following along court drama but
it works I mean people really wanted to
know people who were stopping me on the
street and saying come on tell me did
you do it this I had never experienced
before right especially because it's a
comedy so it's like you think that that
would be an afterthought rebel really
are wrapped up in them in the whodunit
part they're not asking Churchill
questions we all know how that turned
out that's the nice thing about history
no surprise endings yeah you are
finished with the crown - I don't know
why it's in the prep sheet that season -
there's obviously there's no more for
you to do there I did do a tiny little
flashbacks oh but I did it over a year
ago you know I I wrapped up my
participation in the crown a year ago in
February so Wow they said the Queen saw
it somebody got her to actually hers one
her son's I guess got her to a print
Edward told her to watch it and she
liked it she loved her things little
dramatize but overall they said she
liked it well you might know more than I
do
I mean there it's one of the whole ideas
of the series that Royals never tell you
just never know what their lives are
like right they certainly don't express
opinions to the public have you met any
of them I've met Charles on three
occasions we might have to talk about
this last time I don't remember my
memory is really bad do I ask that last
time Sam I don't remember hearing about
it okay so was it me too
well I have been in three performances
where he was in the audience and at the
end there is a kind of greeting line and
you meet Charles and exchanged a few
kind of banal sentences with him what
did you say to him
well you just let him take the lead
there's a and he'll comment on some
completely dull aspect of what he's just
seen there absolute experts at making
inconsequential small talk really
because they're not supposed to have an
opinion on any level they can't have you
going and doing an interview being like
you know we really that's right you're
never going to find him in this chair
right chatting amiably with us about
what he really thinks about anything did
he mention something completely that
Davidian yeah I nine laws yeah I
remember once he can there was a big
royal command performance in Southern
California actually of the Royal
Shakespeare Company and I went with my
wife and when we met him at intermission
she actually engaged him about tony
blair this was long before anybody had
heard of Tony Blair over here but Tony
Blair had been in school with Charles
and in fact had been in a in a play of
Shakespeare play with him I believe I
have this right and and my wife Mary
actually had a genuine chat with Charles
everybody was kind of surprised that he
was opening up that much to her my my
darling wife is a Montana gal and very
kind of
informal and loosened in a certain point
sheep on the shoulder and everybody in
the Union like 50 people in the room
their spine is suddenly stiffen yet I
was so proud of but he probably didn't
care no used to lie that he was having
such a great chat with her
yeah well that never happens nobody's
ever got the balls to do that but never
it somehow didn't occur to her that it
was inappropriate I talked to someone I
forget who it was but they worked with
Michael Jackson might have been Chuck
Zito or some guy and he did something
like he grabbed Michael and he hugged
him I might have been an actor we spoke
to because everybody was horrified
because nobody touches Mike but when you
do it they like they appreciate your
treatment like a real person
I remember meeting Hillary Clinton it
was not the first time I'd met her but
she was the host of the State Department
dinner at the Kennedy Center Honors
which she did every year she was
Secretary of State and loved doing it I
met her she had this huge smile and we
met once or twice before and I leaned I
lunged forward and kissed her on the
cheek and that was probably the least
appropriate thing I'd ever done yeah did
she react poorly to it oh she was
beaming you grabbed him by the face and
kissed him on the mat no she loved she
loved that evening she was being honored
well it was a five or six honorees of
that year I think Meryl Streep yo-yo ma
you know big heavy hitters in the arts
what's amazing about royalty though is
that like you just said there'll be
there'll be a meeting line to meet
Charles after your performance like
generally I'd like somebody goes to a
performance and they get to go back and
meet yeah yeah after you're done
performing you gotta go back Charles but
it was a big deal there was another
occasion the the big I think one hundred
and fiftieth celebration of the music
the Academy of Music in Philadelphia and
she and Camilla were there I met Camilla
on that occasion you get very nervous
knowing they're in the audience you do
yeah it's I don't know somehow being
conscious of anybody in the audience
makes it that just that little bit more
intense but most performers won't admit
that like you ask a performer like nah
no I just did I was going to ask you if
they're nervous I didn't think I'm glad
well you know a lot of actors don't like
to be told there's anybody in the
audience it's much easier dealing with
an audience if it feels completely
anonymous I remember once I was in a
play and a good friend of mine an actor
Jonathan Pryce from England was in the
audience wasn't he in Glengarry Glen
Ross in England he was not he was in the
film he was the engineer in Miss Saigon
and won the Tony Award for he's a
marvelous British actor he's he he a
good friend and Mike Nichols the great
Mike Nichols for both in the audience I
was so conscious of them out there in
the audience that at a certain point I
completely went up on my words in the
middle of a big argument scene big high
point intense scene I was suddenly
completely lost so what did you how did
you get back to where you supposed to be
oh the at Mike the actor on stage with
me Boyd games he sort of managed to get
me back on track but it was it was about
it was probably about six seconds it
felt like about an hour of total heart
attack and you know your peers these
great actors are out there watching well
you can think of his the beat me is your
friends watching you yeah screw the food
and you totally forgot the liner you put
the wrong line we now just totally
forgot it's like I didn't know where I
was and there is nothing to do because
what are you going to talk about to be
another theme oh my god it was I
probably probably intensely dramatic
moment and in fact nobody seemed to have
noticed it yet it's always part of the
performance yeah right the that's the
best part of one of the best parts about
doing radio is that like I'll get
freaked out like that when I find out
certain people have listened to a show
but it's not until after the show's done
yeah I'm like I didn't realize like you
were listening to that but I did I'm
never on Chiss of it as it's happening
yeah I prefer not to know I knew De
Niro's in the audience wants how years
ago at the Comedy Cellar huh and he was
back they were doing research for
something he's in the back of the room
and I'm on stage
I was doing a clean set can I think I
Jimmy Kimmel coming up I do a joke I
hear like the ha it was like the Mack
Katie laughs from a theatre it was Bob
De Niro it was him Oh God we were in the
back but it was it why did you smoke in
a cigar
no but it would have bothered anybody
but he had it was his laughs and then
the next joke I tripped on on bombed
because I became so well oh yeah but he
had just lied about it amazing the
things that happen to your brain yeah
god yes is there anybody that you want
to meet that you haven't because I mean
you've been you know you've met so many
yeah people throughout your being in
show business in general I guess oh I
don't know the people I really get
impressed with her fantastic athletes
really yeah I still never met LeBron
James that would be a treat
yeah I'd owe you a big basketball fan
just like him Oh both both I just I just
watched the basketball last night these
guys are superhuman I'm so bummed out
though that it looks like LeBrons naka I
mean I don't wanna jinx it but it looks
like LeBron is not going to get really
nice no there we go close to it last
night and you want like because I want
has he gotten one for Cleveland yeah
yeah oh yeah I guess last last year yeah
yeah yeah the big but but I want like
LeBron to be this like invincible
superhero Jordan level guide yeah like
they're you would owe many good wouldn't
be sports fans if things were to the
stake though right that if you just knew
like wow LeBron can't get this one again
yeah yeah I guess but I'm a pro
wrestling fan so I like the good guy did
you keep winning and winning and winning
and winning I know the feeling I don't I
don't watch basketball anymore but he's
kind of interesting I mean I don't even
know that the championship was happening
till they were down to nothing I'm like
really psycho yeah I haven't paid
attention to
unbelievable teams yeah it's really do
you go to games yeah when I can you
can't get back to meet LeBron you
jealous I actually i sat in lebron seats
in philadelphia once but i never got to
meet him Wow I had gotten to know his
one of his team his entourage was all in
the hotel and they got me in to give it
a link I mean the first celebrity that
was known to really start going was
Nicholson going to Laker
and that was a big deal yeah did he
still go or no well I think he does I'm
not sure but I'm sure I can't imagine a
Laker game without him would you put
that if you found out LeBron was a Harry
and Henderson Sam this is the kind of
thing to just love I can't even believe
that these guys have even seen me really
yeah you know what I mean
they probably have them grew up all of
them sure you know they all know no I
know fans but you're all still you're
always surprised yeah you get surprised
when people you like recognize you yeah
yeah different worlds you know who was
the last person that uh that you really
were you admired that was like I'm just
a big fan of yours oh gosh well I guess
Prince Charles varies somehow you don't
picture people watching you right I was
told that Hillary and Bill were in a
deep funk quite understands
understandably after the election they
say hey hold up in Chappaqua and binge
watched the crown really I was found
that very touching yeah just you you
like knowing that people watch you it's
gotta be odd but on your level I
wouldn't think you're shocked by it but
it's kind of encouraging you know they
used to get surprised by it yeah yeah
it's I don't know it's a funny thing
throwing it out there to you you're just
you're in your own little world or
you're in a world with a bunch of other
actors and it's kind of funny too
I mean you must experience the same
thing there thousands of people
listening to you right now if not
millions and you don't really think of
them it's just the three of us in a room
talking was she on an individual you
Almon right of like the audience is a
group yeah and then when you realize
it's individual people who are like no I
love the show and I listen every day and
I'm a person who lives my life that way
and you're like oh my god in fact if you
do think about it it sort of freezes you
up yes not yourself when you go to like
a party or Thursday or you do you have
access to everything you want like you
we go to like a big place is always an
area I can't get into there's always
like oh that's where I want to be I
can't get in there like oh you're that
you're a pre-party guy you're not
so yeah I think absolutely everybody has
that experience at some point you know
do I really belong here it's kind of by
the way this is exactly
Beatriz at dinner yeah this this movie
that we opened this week this is the
position that Salma Hayek's character
what is it about it's about a dinner as
in the title I play a billionaire real
estate developer this dinner is three
hugely wealthy men and their three wives
six people but by a couple of turns of
plot there's a seventh guest and it is
this Mexican immigrant physical
therapist kind of spiritual healer who
takes care of the woman of the house who
has served gotten stuck in their house
because her car breaks down and gets
offhandedly invited to dinner and it's a
very curious situation in which case
people rich people who are usually only
communicating with each other
rightly have to deal with someone from a
totally different hell and a lot of help
well that's I was going to ask you like
you've been to a lot of parties in your
character in the movie is like I don't
want to say racist but certainly I think
he's the Alpha guest and he's he's the
most powerful man in the room yeah he's
he's condescending toward immigrants and
is almost unconsciously superior right
yeah have you encountered they add not
ask me to mention names but is that
person that character is that somebody
that you have encountered at at parties
in over various times yeah you go to
parties and I mean great big high
rollers who produce films as a hobby you
know they'll throw a great big Oscar
party and you're at their unbelievable
home in Los Angeles that you didn't even
know existed and you suddenly realize
wow I am out of my element here
but so much of the Hollywood community
is liberal and so I would think that the
opinions that your character had in this
movie they don't really line up with
that
so is that it is that take something
that you get from from rich people you
know in your business I mean as for
the movie this is very clever film
written by Mike White directed by Miguel
Arteta it sort of deliver deliberately
throws off absolutely everybody it it
takes all your expectations and up ends
them so this so that this man who of
course by any eat from what you already
know about the film you assume he's the
villain of the piece but he has other
aspects to him he surprises you with how
convincing he is when he's trying to
persuade Beatriz of his worldview it's
really great it's so far from being
black and white all of the different
issues that get debated I'm talking
about it as if it's a very serious film
in fact it's a very funny and ironic
film that just gets extremely
complicated and challenging as yeah
wrong we don't do something like that
like you play a guy who has to convince
somebody or you have to have a totally
different opinion you might really have
do you ever change the way you actually
feel like are you able to like when you
look at it like your job is to convince
this woman of something that you John
Lithgow might not put do you look at
that going there that actually is a
pretty good point
uh well it's I know that it's it's
unsettling it is unsettling to me and to
like-minded people you know we all all
of us travel in worlds of groupthink you
know my friends basically have my
politics we have there's this character
says things that are so alarming and yet
you know you hear it on TV people do say
these things it there's a terrific
tension you just create this kind of
anxiety the fact that a man like this
will save these things with blithely as
if as if they're they're the God's truth
how do you convince yourself when you're
saying it to to make it believable well
you're just play-acting and you know you
you know a good script when you see one
you know the impact that is seem like
that is going to have and it's a very
complex and ironic in
and you don't feel comfortable in most
part I'm surprised to hear that to the
you sit in and you feel out of your
element like with those in the original
party yeah but everybody does at some
point there's always somebody richer
right like there's like levels of
richness just keep going up and up and I
that or you know yeah yeah I go I go all
week Mead when I meet hotshot athletes
guys oh God you know you're sort of
breathless with admiration who have you
met that really kind of stopped doing
attract up Michael Jordan you met
Michael yeah how did that happen well
Phil Jackson is a very good friend of
mine and when he was like ouch went he
was the coach of the Bulls
I had a great entree and met all those
guys and there was actually a moment
when all the cast of third Rock from the
Sun went to Chicago to do the Oprah show
and I invoked my Phil Jackson privileges
and got us all into Bulls game and we
met them all in fact Dennis Rodman gave
me his autographed his sweaty
autographed jersey you shall have it
you know I somehow I think he was stolen
from now my hotel room isn't that awful
that's amazing a game you assigned
Rodman sure and it was a period when he
was doing that after every Jersey or a
dress it was a very very sweaty jerk
Jersey you know we could have proved by
DNA sure it is but sadly it had
disappeared somewhere along we surprised
to see him in North Korea with Kim Jong
hoon isn't it weird how things work out
you know this is a crazy world really is
nuts that's what I love about acting the
fact that people will do anything and it
exposes you to like being an athlete of
being an actor exposes you to people
that you should never be exposed but you
know they like the fact that Kim Jong
who likes him right right like what an
odd thing that him and his father were
big Bulls fans yeah and I can't get
Jordan to come over I'm sure they can't
get some of the other guys or Pippen now
I'll have to find out if he's a third
Rock fan what I was about to say I'm
sure like the same level of weirdness
happens like there's got to be just ad
people they could be the most despicable
people on earth but their escape yeah
let there one happy place is watching
like reruns of third there's a sort of
anthropological aspect acting going out
and just looking at how bizarre people
can be yeah yeah including world-class
famous people yeah you're entertaining
people some who are great and some who
are terrible like that's the you know oh
my god Paul Potts a big fan you don't
know love I have a fan letter from Paul
Pott in fact joke that was the greatest
thing I've ever heard
have you got weird or obsessive fan mail
I'm sure in the amount of time you've
been doing it you've sure in the type of
roles you've had you've had to attract a
couple of you I don't I don't read a lot
of it I have gotten the most wonderful
responses from from people on for the
crown for the Winston Churchill
performances that have just come in by
email I got an email from Dustin Hoffman
out of out of the blue Wow who might
have met a couple of times in passing
but we're not friends it's just that
kind of thing What did he say to you
just how much he enjoyed it he says you
know it's not easy compliment any other
another actor but I just have to in this
case something like that very Dustin but
you know that that makes you pay
attention not easy complimenting another
actor is that do you think that's more
like it's hard because it's fairly
competitive or certain guys try not to
watch I think he was making fun of
himself in all actors oh yeah it is a
we're all we're all prone to envy you
know there's plenty of people who are
doing things I wish I'd got and I know
the opposite is true
have you auditioned recently like in the
last two years and not gotten something
you've ordered simpler or used to become
an offer on an audition in years I'm
lucky that way sometimes I actually I
have been offered jobs and I've said you
know let me come in and work with you on
this
but I let's audition this for each other
just because I I myself want to know
whether this I'm doing a workshop in a
couple of weeks of a piece of work which
I just want to see whether it works or
not you want to see if you can pull it
off at if it feels right yeah are there
times where you go like I don't think I
can do this well yeah
in those cases I turn it down Wow but
you know I have to say some of the most
interesting things that I've ever done I
mean interesting for me and big
breakthroughs from for me
I've been bright ideas other people had
which I never would have had for myself
Winston Churchill being one of them
what was do you that Saturday you would
have seen yourself doing man I would
have been who came to you and said this
is really something you should ever the
director himself Stephen Daldry who's a
marvelous director I'd always wanted to
work with him so it was like well if he
believes in me and this job I'm
certainly not going to say no I was
scared to death to do it but I wasn't
going to turn it down when did you get
comfortable with the role like I would
imagine as soon as I started working
with the makeup and costume people you
started to see what it's gonna look like
I really helped me yes and also arriving
in England and having all these English
actors welcomed me and like it was a
great idea to have me play the part that
made an enormous it's like what you have
all these people around it's like that I
look I might be wrong but I don't think
they're all wrong yeah okay like they
had more confidence in me than I had in
myself yeah you know we start doing the
accent a big part were you nervous about
having to do the accent uh yeah little I
had a terrific dialect coach who was
working just as much with the English
actors as with me I mean it was a very
different sound to the dialects back in
the early 1950s among the Royals so
there was this strong sense that we were
all in this together
and what was it was there any part of it
that was particularly hard you know they
won't be hard
acting is bad writing and this was such
brilliant writing Peter Morgan
he he wrote to Churchill's
contradictions and insecurities and his
old age and his fear of growing old and
losing his viability all these great
things that you can grab on to when a
writer is helping you out that much it's
not hard it's amazing that Prince
Phillip just stopped doing whatever the
Royal duty as literally a few months ago
he's like 95 95 he's like and she's 19
he's like I'm done with this crap sick
and tired of shaking people's hands you
know see just kinda I guess he's
retiring is that what does that lead
from those duties you know which means
no more official stuff you know no more
ribbon cutting so you're saying you're
exhausted before because of the just a
promotional tool you're on is it tougher
now because I mean I I like what's
happened in film in the sense that I
don't liked it you can't get a regular
movie in theaters anymore that's not
like a blockbuster action thing but I do
like that smaller movies have found a
way to reach an audience and that's
through you know small theater release
and digital really on things like that
like those are it's not like it used to
be with straight to home video it's
viable and it's it's real and you can
see great films this way but is it is it
more difficult to spread the word about
a movie like this because you need to
reach the audience directly like you're
you I implore you to find this film yeah
it's part of the bargain you you you
have to pitch in to help raise awareness
for yeah particularly in the independent
film because they have low budgets for
producing the film but low budgets for
promoting them to the end you don't get
paid much to do the film and you don't
get paid anything to promote it but you
have a tremendous emotional investment
and especially a film like this which is
so fine you know it's the industry is
very interesting you know just watching
the ebb and flow the different trends
studio filmmaking is the franchise
business my last two films were pitched
pick three and daddy's home to both out
around Christmas time good reliable you
know recei quills to hugely successful
films that's that's kind of the studio
business not to mention the comic book
franchises which means that independent
films are almost a different industry
now and yet they are esteemed even more
I mean you don't see the franchise films
nominated for Oscars except in technical
areas right none of the actors are given
acting nominations that that has
gradually become the the purview of very
small independent and for want of a
better word artistic films yeah art
films films with real aspirations the
same aspiration a playwright has putting
a play on in off Broadway in New York
this and Beatriz dinner is just a
perfect example of that and it comes out
tomorrow and select theaters where's a
list of ways people can find this movie
well it's only in New York and LA ok
first week and then I think it goes much
wider June 16th or some okay so you can
google it yeah the court and it will
come out digitally I'm sure and that's
been that's become like one of my new
favorite things to do is like iTunes or
whatever it is we hop up with these
movies thing I've never heard of it
would you'll see it before you mind it
it's it's extraordinary the response
we've gotten so far as I say it's hard
for a little movie like this to break
through one thing that is very much in
our favor is the current political
situation suddenly you know the movie
was made long before this political sea
change but as soon as November came
along the film was all done but it
suddenly was a different film yeah it
meant something else yeah well I'm
looking forward to it and the way you
sold it sounds really interesting I
would like to see it well we have a sec
right before you go did you work with
John Cena and daddy's home - oh yeah how
is he hahaha
guy yeah a really good actor yeah I
guess that's what wrestling does for you
yeah turns you into a good actor
daddy's home to is going to be great I
will be back here to talk with you about
that definite okay I can I'll ask you
all my John Cena questions that yeah I
would mention Will Ferrell Mark Wahlberg
and Mel Gibson
I mean it's Wow since I we got a lot to
talk about that and yeah you should
alright we'll see you next time and it's
called beatriz my saying right batteries
batteries at dinner but you're the only
person who's pronounced it right I did
just because I told you yeah absolutely
yeah I listen to I just repeated what
you said immediately I parrot it it
seems like theaters tomorrow in New York
in LA and then June 6 that comes out in
wider release and John Lithgow on
Twitter am i saying it wrong yeah let's
go but let's go I am saying wrong John
let's go ah you can pronounce it any way
you like except Kelsey Grammer oh yeah
you're turning it turns out roll down
well it's not good for you yeah for you
a big problem with Kelsey and John we'll
talk about that next time too